I know in Creede Rocky Balboa is  supposed to eat he's older now and he's  supposed to be punchy from his long  boxing career but I think the filmmakers  laid that part on a little too thick  check out this scene where rocky first  meets the son of Apollo Creed how good  was he  Apollo yeah he was great he was a  perfect fighter ain't nobody ever better  anyway cookie died he came to talk to  you right trained you brought you back  and you know all this how do you think  what are you like a cousin there what  are you uh  nephew or you like is uncle this  grandson but granddaughter  maybe like you're his cardiologist those  tomato gotta tell me if you were ghosts  you know my father just a second I mean  you can be honest with me like we see  your mother  [Applause]  hey thanks for watching please subscribe  to my youtube channel so they will stop  making me shoot these videos please